I like you just the way you are imagine
you came home from school every day you
didn't go on the internet you didn't
play flappy bird and instead you turn on
PBS to watch a guy in a cardigan who
accepted you no matter what that was mr.
Rogers it's you I like it's not the
things you weigh put on those shoes that
sweater
you fed is fish look at these fish
because if they're dancing watching mr.
Rogers neighborhood was kind of like
visiting your grandparents except you
actually liked going especially to the
neighborhood of make-believe I'm glad
you're the way you are I'm glad you're
you shouldn't rely on gimmicks to hold
your attention the set looked like
something you'd make in your basement
and the puppets were worn from years of
play and affection showing that you
don't need much to have an amazing
adventure just a bit of imagination he
treated you like an equal how do I turn
your music on here push boy okay
we learned with him about how crayons
are made one of those boxes has 16
different color crayons in divorce my
mother and dad what's wrong with them
babe they fight all the time
Fred Rogers never condescended to his
audience he's simply taught and listened
he was the best friend of countless
children over the years when you wash
mr. Rogers anything seemed possible 895
episodes for decades one man it's a
beautiful day in this neighborhood a
beautiful day for a neighbor
all of us have special ones who have
loved us into being would you just take
along with me 10 seconds to think of the
people who have helped you become who
you are please won't you be my neighbor
my neighbor